previously on coffeezilla this case
isn't an ordinary one for all the crypto
you've been talking about lately you've
overlooked the biggest fraud of all what
do you mean
have you ever heard of a coin called
tether
no seriously what do you know about
tether that wasn't rhetorical
oh sorry i was trying to be cool well
stop it
it's cringe okay okay um wait what was
the question again
never mind i'll just tell you imagine
for a second you had a money printer
a real one so basically the government
correct but imagine it's not controlled
by a centralized government
imagined it's owned offshore unaudited
unaccountable that's impossible no one
would ever accept that currency
tether is that money printer only a few
days ago
one billion dollars worth of tether was
printed out of thin air
before that a billion more it's in
circulation today
i think i need another drink sorry
explain this from the beginning
how does tether work no problem but
you're gonna need a lot more than one
drink
oh oh
man what happened last night
i need some coffee
oh no no
okay come on stephen what time is it
oh boy all right we gotta gotta make
this video already uh
come on remember why you do this okay
okay come on we can do this we can do
this
hey guys welcome to hey guys welcome to
come on come on stephen got a video to
make
okay hey guys welcome to a special
episode
inside of the 10 million dollar studio
today we have a very special episode
if my head would stop pounding for a
second sorry you wouldn't believe the
night i had even if i told you but none
of that matters okay look because i got
to get this video out
after all i always remind myself why i
do this
for the fans so today we need to talk
about tether
tether is suspicious maybe it's not
fully backed they're creating more out
of thin air and then using that
to buy and accumulate bitcoin because
there is no transparency in tether
that's the problem
is they were issuing tether in whenever
it was needed out of thin air it was not
backed by dollars
there might be a fair amount of gambling
mentality coming into that trust
tether is a cryptocurrency that well the
best i can explain it is either
deeply misunderstood or the biggest
fraud in the
world in this video i want to lay out
evidence and let you decide
for yourself is tether a fraud legally i
can't say that it is you know but if it
is
and that is a big juicy legally
compliant
if it's about to be bigger than bernie
madoff for context
bernie madoff's victims lost 64.8
billion dollars
the current value of tether is 62
billion and at its current rate of
growth it climbs a billion dollars
every four days by the time you're
watching this the value of tether will
be more than madoff
ever had in investor funds now if it's
not fraud
and that is possible this video will be
about bureaucratic incompetence
and lies now maybe this is the first
time you're hearing of tether or stable
coins and you're thinking
i don't hold any tether so i don't have
to worry about this video right i'll
just hold bitcoin but here's the problem
even if you're not invested in tether
you are exposed to the fallout of a
tether crash
whether you realize it or not see tether
is the backbone of liquidity in the
crypto market it's
one of the main ways people buy
cryptocurrencies and it's the largest
crypto by trading volume
even bigger than bitcoin so if tether
disappears overnight
all that liquidity disappears and the
price of crypto could come crashing down
all crypto not just tether so that's my
quick soft pitch for why
tether is important and why you should
sit here and listen
to what is probably going to be a very
long video which at times will feel like
the accompanying audio book to this
image
all right before we get started i want
to do some real quick housekeeping and
address some criticisms
right off the bat this video will be
labeled unfortunately as fud
by most of the crypto world this is an
acronym crypto fans use to dismiss
criticism
it means fear uncertainty and doubt but
the way crypto influencers use it you'd
think it was more like an enchanting
spell
to keep the mean old bear market away
here's how the average crypto youtuber
will respond when you show them this
video
but there's also more fun the latest fun
i should say i'm gonna dress the fun i
think it's just fun
and also why i think uh we should ignore
it
it's all fud all the time bad fud i do
not like that fud
i do not agree with that fud i will
ignore that fud
look you don't have to agree with my
opinions on tether or conclude that it's
a fraud in this video
as i said i'm happy if you decide either
way all i ask is you keep an open mind
and watch the whole video
before deciding you were right all along
number two this video
is not attacking crypto as a whole i'm
still invested in multiple tokens and i
plan to stay that way
it's because i'm invested in crypto for
the long haul and i think in the five to
ten year time horizon this won't matter
if it does matter well we're all going
die together boys i mean that's all i
can say
but that said i do think it matters in
the short term i think tether matters a
whole lot
and the bigger tether is allowed to grow
unchecked the greater risk
they pose to the crypto ecosystem as a
whole all right with those things out of
the way
let me explain tether as fast as i can
okay so first things first
what is tether first we should
distinguish that tether limited is the
company that produces
tether coins tether coins or simply
tethers
are what is known as a stable coin in
crypto they call it a stable coin
because that's exactly what it's
supposed to be
stable one usdt for example is always
supposed to be worth
exactly one dollar stable get it now
technically stable coins can be pegged
to anything you can have a stable coin
for a euro you can have a stable coin
for
gold you can have a stable coin for
anything and stable coins are useful for
a lot of reasons they let you get around
regulation easier
you can keep us cash on foreign crypto
exchanges and many other fancy things
but back when tether was created in 2014
it was the first of its kind early on
this was tether's number one claim
every tether is always backed one to one
by traditional currency
held in our reserves so one usdt is
equivalent to one
usd and how it was supposed to work in
theory
was that you would give tether one
dollar and they'd minch you
one tether you could then go spin that
tether on crypto or whatever you wanted
and if you ever wanted to redeem that
tether you could go back to tether
limited
the company give them your tether and
they'd give
back to you your one dollar and then
they'd burn that tether token so it
doesn't exist anymore
thus maintaining the exact balance of
money in tethers reserves
to the number of tethers that have been
issued in theory that's how it's
supposed to work
here comes the first sign of trouble see
people started to notice that
actually in tether's terms of service
heather doesn't actually have to redeem
anything
if they don't want to it's literally in
writing right here
tether reserves the right to delay the
redemption or withdrawal of tether
tokens
then again if you didn't believe me even
more specifically
tether reserves the right to redeem
tether tokens by in-kind redemptions of
securities
in other words if you decide you don't
want these tethers anymore
and want them redeemed by tether as was
always intended
they do not have to give you your money
back but look look look
i can hear you guys already i'm sure
you're saying look this is just fud just
fun
ignore it everything's fine as long as
the money's there right
thank goodness tether is a transparent
company that publishes their reserves
daily only wait a minute this section
has been changed
see going to the wayback machine back in
2017
tether promised that their reserve
holdings are published daily and
are subject to frequent professional
audits
whoops it's actually been half a decade
and there hasn't been
a single audit so i guess the boys
decided it was better to scrub that from
the website real quick
and change it but don't worry guys some
of the executives at tether are willing
to assure us
that there's no cause for alarm the
money's there i agree that could be
handled better
but um i can all i can say is that
money's there i promise you that money's
there we promise you that
i'm sure that's the thing crypto fans
love to hear you know the same people
who made their rallying cry
don't trust verify yeah i'm sure
promises are basically the
same thing right but don't blame tether
it's not their fault see
if you keep playing that call we were
just listening to you'll hear the real
reason
for the lack of an audit and you know
we're constantly looking for solutions
to
to make that more transparent it's not
that easy you know
there's so much negativity surrounding
it that nobody nobody wants to touch it
auditors don't want to work with us
other people it's just
i don't know what quite what to say
about it i mean it's like heisenberg's
uncertainty principle
everybody looking at it actually affects
the system that's right
if you look too close at their funds
they may just vanish
heisenberg's uncertainty principle maybe
it's more like madoff's uncertainty
principle but according to tether that
really is the reason they haven't been
audited in six years
it's that securing an audit from a top
auditor is difficult they simply
can't find one but that actually isn't
true
the truth is they actually had an
auditor someone ready to do an audit
someone named friedman llp but in 2018
tether bailed in the middle of the audit
complaining that friedman was being too
and i'm quoting here
excruciatingly detailed um yes you heard
me right the reason an
offshore digital dollar printer can't
get an audit is not because they
couldn't find one
it's because the auditor that actually
agreed to it was asking for too much
information sorry guys no audit today
too busy
changing the financial system look
audits are too
time-consuming according to tether but
don't worry
even though tether doesn't have to
redeem your crypto bucks and
even though they've never been audited
despite saying they would be
it's actually the least of your worries
see you should get
really concerned when another shady
company
enters the picture with ties to tether
that company
is bitfinex and i know what you're
thinking another stupid name that's
confusing and i get it
writing the script it's kind of like
trying to explain the plot of a
christopher nolan movie
and not the good one just bear with me
okay bitfinex is a crypto exchange like
coinbase
and early on it was the most popular
crypto exchange where people could buy
and sell cryptocurrencies
pretty soon people got pretty suspicious
of the ties of tether and bitfinex
bitfinex was the first and main exchange
where tethers were traded for a long
time
so people began thinking if let's just
say somehow
the largest crypto exchange and larger
stablecoin were somehow in bed together
that'd be kind of bad because after all
an exchange could collude with that
stablecoin
to get to a place where they're
basically infinitely printing tethers
using those tethers to go buy bitcoin on
the exchange they own
and it'd always be worth a dollar on
that exchange use them to back those
tethers or convert it to usd
and then you just never redeem the
tethers huge pile of cash
from absolutely nowhere crypto certainly
wouldn't be new to such a complicated
scheme
mount gox and quadriga cx were both
crypto exchanges
that use their ownership to profit and
ultimately
rip off a lot of people they both
eventually went bust
so people were understandably concerned
and they asked directly
are bitfinex and tether owned by the
same people and of course
bitfinex and tether replied with the
tried and true strategy of
everyone who has nothing to hide they
lied
here's chief strategy officer phil
potter denying this
saying the tether and bifidex i just
banked at the same bank
so people that people that are confused
right now basically
tether is phoenix right uh
no it's not but we bank with the same
banks
ah this has to be the worst excuse of
all time
oh we just we bank at the same banks no
relation we just see each other in line
with drawing
huge sums of cash no we just say hi to
each other across across little cubicles
it's ridiculous look fast forward to
2017
of course the truth comes out after the
paradise papers are released you know
those like major league of offshore
shell company documents
it turns out one of the companies leaked
in that
was tether and it was revealed that in
fact bitfinex and tether weren't just in
bed together
they were owned by the same people
that's right
phil potter and juan carlos divisini
both had their names on tethers
incorporation
and here's phil potter later revising
his lie we
bifidax are majority owners of a bit of
tether
this is true but tether is a completely
segregated entity
um dollars are all there isn't it so
funny that he always has to reassure
people hey
dollars are there now at this point i
think it's becoming obvious that the
owners of bitfinex and tether aren't
exactly
your typical executives so i'd like to
introduce you guys to
exactly who's behind these two companies
which are basically
the same company they're owned by the
same people
because at its heart this is really a
story about
trust can tether or bitfidex be
trusted we've already established
multiple lies
but now let's look at the background of
these individuals i contacted a man
named bennett tomlin for this
he investigates fraud full time and is
currently writing an entire book
about tether i asked him to break down
the background of these individuals
and here's what he told me bitfinex was
founded
in uh 2013 by rafael nicolet
by day was a help desk technician and by
night spent his time
looking on bitcoin talk for ponzi
schemes he could participate in
famously he lost a bunch of his bitcoin
in the trend in shavers ponzi scheme
which was later brought down by the
department of justice
and then he tried to start his own
high-yield lending program
where people could lend him their
bitcoins and he would
use what he called arbitrage to earn
them a guaranteed two percent per week
on their bitcoins
after people were not interested in
giving their money to a ponzi schemer he
decided to start bitfinex
he was later joined at biffin x by juan
carlo de vacini
currently the chief financial officer
for both bitfinex and tether
who previously was a software pirate
he got in trouble for selling pirated
microsoft
uh software and that was a lot of money
wasn't it like that he got in trouble
for
no it was a relatively small amount uh
it it's a currency conversion factor
makes it seem bigger than it was
it was like i want to say it was like 18
million lira which at the time converted
to
i wanna say like a hundred thousand usd
so it's a relatively small fine for that
yeah and so then they were later joined
by uh phil potter who for a long time
was the chief strategy officer of
bitfinex
he came from the new york financial
scene he was once profiled
in a new york times piece where he
bragged about his wealth and how much
money he was making
and very shortly after that he lost his
position at morgan stanley
and then tether was started by initially
a different
cast of characters led by brock pierce
brock pierce was a famous child actor
who starred
in films like the mighty ducks he's
more known for fleeing to spain
with indicted child sexual predator mark
collins rector
where both of them ended up getting
arrested in
a house full of child pornography
he started initially realcoin which
became tether along with a couple of
other people
who he had previously worked with
including jonathan yantis
who helped him at ige which was a
company that started
surrounding farming mmo items so they
would hire out people in various
countries to earn these items and then
would sell them
secondary market yeah and then realcoin
was bought out by bitfinex and became
tether
and when it was incorporated had
basically the same executive team as
bitfinex
what can you tell us about paulo who
later joined the team
apollo is a little bit interesting
because he doesn't have the same kind
of past that some of these other
characters do him and his wife claudia
who is the chief operating officer for
bitfinex both joined
in i want to say 2015
they both had a previous history as
fintech developers
and as far as i can tell they seem to be
competent fintech developers
uh the most interesting thing to me
about paulo is one that it's him and his
wife working together
for bitranex and tether and two
that so there was a document leaked that
at one point
bitfinex leaked that showed that paolo
was one of the directors for
dell chain which is the it's
a cryptocurrency focused offshoot of
deltek bank which is where
tether now banks and so it seems that
paolo might
be connected pretty deeply to tethers
bank
tell me about stu hogner their general
counsel
so yeah stuart hogner is the general
counsel for bitfinex and tether
he has a history in cryptocurrency and
also
in online gambling he was the director
of compliance
at excapa which was a online poker
company most known for being the parent
company for
ultimate vet ultimate bet
got in trouble because they were giving
some of their players
a god mode that allowed them to see the
other poker's
players cards which would obviously be
an advantage
if you're trying to play poker so that
happened
uh well stu was the director of
compliance for excapa and then shortly
thereafter he left
this is all shocking because these are
the people sort of facilitating the
currency that is the backbone
of crypto um it's like the leading
liquidity provider
and what you're telling me is these are
not
savory individuals for the most part
that's exactly what i'm telling you
this is starting to look bad huh but
don't worry
it gets way worse around 2017 okay
people began
criticizing tether sort of seriously for
the first time
and it started with someone named
bitfinext on twitter
bitfinex has been by far the most vocal
critic of tether
and i interviewed him to ask him what
made him first suspect
something was wrong starting in late
march 2017
i noticed unusual trading on bitfinex
that seemed to
match the trading that i saw on mount
gox when mount gox lost banking
i was alert but had nothing concrete
about their banking situation
until april the 5th 2017 when bitfinex
attempted to sue wells fargo
their lawsuit indicated that they
bitfinex and tether
had no banking at all and despite this
tether continued to issue tens of
millions of dollars
of tether despite bitfenix and tether
being unable to receive
transfers i suspected fraud
and started my twitter account now in
response to this criticism
tether panicked and even though they
would never end up getting an
audit they decide to release a third
party attestation
to show that they really had funds in
reserve to back up
their tethers 400 million tethers in
fact but real quick note an attestation
is not an audit an audit is a detailed
forensic look of your accounts and
attestation can be as simple as a peek
into your bank account to see that the
money's there
for a very short amount of time this is
what that attestation
looked like now at the time many saw
this as proof that tether
was in fact backed it sure looked like
they had 400 million dollars in the bank
and everyone in crypto also had good
reason to want to believe this as well
everybody was making money to put it
frankly after all the more money tether
printed the higher bitcoins price would
rise
so it was in everyone's interest who
held bitcoin or crypto for that matter
to keep the gravy train going the only
problem was
with this attestation it turns out that
some funny business was going on
see it was found out later in a new york
attorney general investigation
that something very shady had happened
tether had convinced their third party
to conduct his
attestation or snapshot on a very
specific day
september 15 2017 with noble bank
on september 14th the day before that
happened
tether didn't have an account with noble
bank
on the day of the snapshot or at the
station
tether opened a bank account where they
supposedly had reserves all along
and bit fedex the other company which
they have nothing to do with
transferred 382 million dollars into
that account
that night the attestation was done and
everything appeared
in order but no one knew that the funds
supposedly
backing tether arrived there that day
suspiciously the price of bitcoin also
suddenly fell by around 40 to 50
in the two weeks prior leading some to
believe that someone was selling
bucket loads of bitcoin the price
recovered immediately
after the attestation and was the
largest four hours of buying
in bitcoin's history on the same day
don't forget that only minutes ago phil
potter claimed that tether and bitfinex
were completely separate entities
but tether is a completely segregated
entity
dollars are all there but now we find
that they're actually co-mingling funds
but even this
ruse didn't save bitfenix and tether
completely they may have warded off
public opinion for a little while
but their critics were growing louder
than ever the friedman attestation was
worthless
and i called it as such at the time but
a big shadow loomed over the project
that
not even their critics could have seen
coming you see
around this time bitfinex and tether
were having banking issues
it wasn't uncommon for crypto companies
to have trouble finding banks to work
with after all some of the users of
cryptocurrencies especially early on
were
quite sketchy so banks didn't want to
get involved nonetheless
if you're a crypto company you need a
bank to receive wire deposits so
bitfinex decides to start relying on
something called
crypto capital now this company probably
deserves its
own video crypto capital but suffice to
say they worked with a lot of let's call
it um
needy clients you know people who
couldn't go anywhere else
besides a sketchy non-bank to bank with
people
who needed their money moved without
anyone knowing where it was from
i mean i just say it like money
laundering basically to put it into
perspective for the types of people
crypto capital were working with
the colombian drug cartel were later
implicated
with crypto capital so we're talking
some seriously sketchy
uh business partners here but look
bitfinex is desperate they need banking
so they start working with them
depositing hundreds of millions of their
clients
funds with them and for a while things
were going great
and smoothly but this time it would
prove that bitfinex and tether were the
ones who would be duped
because they trusted somebody see the
feds were onto crypto capital
after an illegal escort website called
backpage was busted
guess who was implicated well you
guessed it crypto capital
and when the feds came knocking
everyone's funds got seized
i mean we're talking the shell account
funds the ones
holding bitfinex's clients money reports
say that at this point
bitfinex had 850 million dollars frozen
in this giant international money
laundering case and i mean this
is huge according to internal documents
in june 2018
bitfinex told their point of contact at
crypto capital
that over 80 of client funds were
controlled
by crypto capital translation that's it
we're insolvent if we can't get access
to those funds that we deposited with
crypto capital
we don't have the money so bitfinex is
even more desperate than ever they can't
find a solution
they're about to blow up just like so
many crypto exchanges have done in the
past
i mean after all there's no way to
magically patch an 850 million dollar
hole
in your balance sheet right
absolutely wrong suddenly bitfinex
realizes they have something
no one else has ever had in their
position a flying lamborg no i'm just
kidding
they have a money printer and this money
printer
also has massive private reserves so
rather than go bankrupt
bitfinex instead takes 400 million
dollars from tethers reserves
and suddenly they can meet withdrawals
and not go out of business they
basically bailed themselves out is what
i'm trying to tell you right now
and meanwhile even though they're still
short tons of cash
they proceed to lie to the public and
issue a statement saying
bitfinex is not solvent and a constant
stream
of medium articles claiming otherwise is
not going to change this now again
they are insolvent they don't have the
money but are we really surprised
that they're lying yet again meanwhile
they're still trying to fight the bad
press of all of this
and so they decide they need another
attestation to show
that their reserves are solid to do this
they get another bank
sorry i know it's like a rotating cast
of banks
just go with me this one's called deltek
okay
funny enough one of the executives is
actually the creator of inspector gadget
which is totally random and weird but at
this point
i could probably tell you anything and
you'd believe me in this story because
it's
so insane but anyways they get this at
the station from deltek and once again
they get back up to their old trick see
on november 1st 2018 tether had deltek
give a public announcement that affirmed
that tether now had a balance of
1.8 billion dollars in reserve they had
grown a lot by then
still making them backed one-to-one
however
after dell tech confirms this november
2nd tether pays
bitfinex 475 million dollars
you know to help plug the hole that's
still in bitfinex's balance sheet and
kind of
make them whole again of course it
naturally follows if you just took 500
million dollars from one company and
handed over to this one
tethers not backed the next day after
they claimed that they were back
of course they lied because it's these
guys right
so shady but of course nobody could have
possibly known that at the time and we
actually didn't find this
out until the new york attorney
general's office released
their investigation this means that what
bitfinex and tether set out to do
succeeded which is deceiving their
customers to buy more time
this means unequivocally at least on
november 2nd
and who knows for how much longer tether
was unbacked by us dollars
and around this time interestingly
tether decided that maybe it was time to
move the goal posts again
so what did they do well around 2019 yet
again
tether's website suddenly changed
without warning after spending five
years claiming to be a hundred percent
backed
by usd they change it to this every
tether token
is a hundred percent backed by our
reserves
not by us dollars which include
traditional currency and cash
equivalents
and from time to time may include other
assets and receivables from loans
made by tether to third parties which
may include affiliated entities
collectively reserves
every tether token is also one to one
peg to the dollar
so they're saying it's still pegged to
the dollar now we don't really know why
though
because they can basically loan an
insolvent parent company or co
company money as much as they want to
bail them out
so what exactly is receivable if that
company goes under
it's a disaster but look look i i don't
want to
bog you down in explaining to you how
completely insane that is
uh it's pretty obvious the much more
obvious question
i think we can all ask ourselves now is
who in their right mind
would trust this company at this point
tether and bitfinex
owned by the same company have
repeatedly lied omitted and misled
people and we've only done a basic
history of what's happened so far
2021 hasn't been much better for them
either the new york attorney general's
office investigated tether
for two years and as a part of a
settlement they were fined
millions of dollars banned from new york
and the attorney general couldn't be
more clear
they say bitfinex recklessly and
unlawfully covered up
massive financial losses to keep their
scheme going and protect their bottom
lines
tethers claims that its virtual currency
was but fully backed by us dollars
at all times was a lie which
wow that's i mean that's quite the
statement so
i bet you're asking yourself tether
finally fessed up right
like that that must be it that must be
where this story ends
but you'd be right in a normal world but
this is crazy land right instead tether
decides that to pretend basically this
was all good news
and in yet another lie but this time
from their uh
general counsel stu hogner they said
that the ag's office
made no negative findings whatsoever the
tethers were not fully backed that is
completely wrong literally the new york
attorney general said
tethers claims that it was fully backed
was a lie stu hoechner the
general counsel says oh they never found
anything made no negative findings that
tethers were not fully backed
uh so look tether and biff and x even
when caught
lie by the new york attorney general
still lie about what even that says now
of course
manny might declare any kind of
settlement for tether at all a win
i mean at least they were shut down and
everything fell apart right so
that that might be true to some extent
but don't forget if this is a
complicated fraud scheme
it wouldn't be unprecedented for
regulators to fail to shut it down
for a long time remember this guy bernie
madoff himself was discovered early on
by independent researchers but
the sec investigated and cleared him
multiple times before the fraud
unraveled but regardless of what you
think about whether tether is
guilty or innocent here one thing
is clear tether's money printer is
running at an all-time
high at the beginning of this year there
were 20 billion
tether in circulation right now
there's 62 billion they've printed 42
billion tether
in like six months and are all those
tethers backed
is tether unbacked well i don't want to
say too much
right i'll let you decide i have my
opinions on it
but either way this story clearly isn't
finished now the last revelation we need
to talk about in this whole debacle
has to be the infamous pie chart tether
released
revealing their reserves breakdown for
the first time previously they had
hidden what their tethers were backed by
after they left the dollar standard but
because of the new york attorney
general's settlement agreement they had
to publish this they were forced to
other people have done full breakdowns
of what all this means
but the big headline here is that tether
has according to them
huge amounts of what they call um
commercial paper 49 of their total
reserves to be precise
real quick by the way i know the number
you're seeing says 65
for commercial paper but that's a
breakdown of the cash or cash
equivalents which only makes up 75
percent of tethers reserves
so in tether's total reserves commercial
paper makes up a total
of 49 which is 75 of 65
i know the way they presented it is
confusing so i just wanted to clarify
what is commercial paper says everyone
in the room
uh well it's unsecured debt it's debt
that if they default on it you don't
have collateral
so in theory i believe commercial paper
is supposed to be
only lint to like a rated um
institutions like you're you're going to
give it to like
apple or microsoft or you know someone
you can trust to not fail because your
debt is unpacked but who is tether
giving that money to
we simply have no idea 49
of 60 billion dollars which is roughly
um
way more than any human can ever spend
theoretically tether could almost lend
anyone
unsecured debt get an iou and according
to them that tether would be
backed meanwhile how much actual cash on
hand does tether have
just about three percent pretty
incredible for a company that claimed
only a short while ago
that it was uh always one-to-one back by
traditional currency held in our
reserves
now every tether is backed one to .03 by
traditional currency
held in its reserves but now that you're
up to speed on tether and their history
maybe it's time to stop talking about
the past and instead
talk about the future and its
implications and this comes to the
opinion part these are my
thoughts okay so this is not fact here
two things seem true to me tether
leadership often lie
and have a long history of being shady
the second thing is that tethers
absolutely massive it has passed
and how much money they're actually
holding not only that according to the
financial times
tethers commercial paper holdings
immediately place it as
quote one of the world's largest
investors in the u.s commercial paper
market
rubbing shoulders with the likes of fund
managers vanguard and blackrock
and dwarfing the investments of tech
giants
like google and apple another quote
further down the article
is even more alarming quote until last
week we really hadn't heard of them
said a trader at a large bank it was
news to us
to put tethers absurd size in another
way that illustrates how weird this is
they are currently the biggest company
in the world in terms of
assets per employee in the world by
far according to linkedin tether has 13
employees but 62 billion under
management
that's almost 5 billion per employee
literally it is the biggest fintech
company
in existence right now tether is huge
which leads to an
kind of obvious conclusion if it's fraud
big if it's going to be really
really really really really bad how bad
i mean it's hard to know crypto
influencers mostly you know the fud ones
uh try to
very hard to paint a rosy picture
pointing out that even if tethers 100
on back tether is only worth 60 billion
compared to the entire crypto market
which is like 2 trillion
and they would say you just kind of take
260 billion out of 2 trillion it's not
that much
however due to tethers special role in
the market i'm not sure i agree
tethers collapse isn't just about 60
billion winking out of existence because
tether is the number one medium of
exchange for people
to get in and out of crypto which means
when that liquidity suddenly disappears
it's gonna be a lot worse than people
think
will bitcoin and crypto survive yeah
probably
will it be pretty will it be just 60
billion dollars
probably not now of course there are
alternate timelines to consider
as well you know maybe tether never
collapses
maybe after years of incompetence lies
in deceit
they righted the ship they're changed
people only time will tell
but just don't say i didn't warn you
well did you tell them i tried to what
now
now we wait
[Music]
please
wake up and smell the coffee